I suppose if we put all the characters
into a mixer and mix them all up you
probably get something pretty close to
who I am in whatever this world is we
call real
I suppose at some point I thought this
was something that I could do and it was
I never thought it was me I don't think
I ever identified with it as as as me
it's a really good job and has given me
extraordinary riches way beyond money
just what I have experienced people have
met situations that challenge me it's
been incredible
so many and it's been very rare that I
have not felt in affinity the creative
process is a very delicate one and
there's got to be something there or you
can't work you can't create a
relationship out of nothing and
certainly on film it sees when there's
nothing to go on that you can't fake
that there have been a few times where I
didn't have a close relationship with
someone and it might even have been
combative but even the combative nature
of it presupposes that there's something
going on and you can work with that you
can do something with that a kind of a
neutral place where you can take it or
leave it it really gives you nothing to
work from you can't be creative in my
space
it's all a process it's not a place you
get to so I would say expansion you keep
expanding what I can keep expanding my
heart and my mind my ability to get
outside of myself that's moving towards
happiness all the time I can trust that
you